und jetzt schaut mal kurz in den chat
freunde denn jetzt zeige ich euch meinen
neuen minecraft namen hallo mein name
ist luca und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video es gibt zwei sachen
die sich 34 voll viele sachen haben sich
einfach geändert zunächst einmal was
euch wahrscheinlich direkt als erstes
aufgefallen ist hier ist ein neues
mikrofonen und ich hoffe ihr mögt die
qualität und ich bin ich bin komplett
begeistert ich zeige euch mal wie das
hier gut aussieht und zwar dass er
einfach mal ein mikrofon mit dem
gelenkarm der steht jetzt ganz simpel
und dann habe ich nur ein sondern bloß
nicht weiß ob die kinder tot aber die
zeit beruhigte 1000 mischpult stehen
noch nie ist vorbei nur noch ein teil
das ganze equipment was ich jetzt am
start habe kostet recht viel allerdings
habe ich mir gedacht die sachen die ich
da vorne hatte sind sechs jahre alt
gewesen und sind quasi auseinander
gefallen deswegen habe ich jetzt einfach
mal was gibt könnte und ich hoffe euch
gefällt die qualität das ist super also
ich finds hammer die zweite sache ist
ich habe einen neuen minecraft account
wie hier ist eventuell der ein oder
andere mitbekommen hat ich glaube es
haben tatsächlich sehr sehr viele
mitbekommen wurde ich nicht nur bei
twitter letztens gehackt sondern auch
bei minecraft beziehungsweise mon cher
und da hab ich nicht mehr zutrifft drauf
weil der typ die e mail adresse geändert
hat und dann mit dem mojang support die
mit denen kann man nichts anfangen hab
den meine daten geschickt ich habe den
sogar meinen führerschein und person
alles zukommen lassen und dass die dann
eventuell sein okay das ist der wirklich
und dann hab ich dir meinen youtube
account geschickt und damit dich
aufnehmen konnte und irgendwie und die
sonne
nee nee nein nein unter heute ja freitag
ist und alle schön und wurde gegen
erwartet natürlich der typische otto
normalverbraucher in deutschland ganz
normal dass minecraft video von luca das
habt ihr jetzt hier mit viele fragen
sich jetzt welchen namen mich derzeit
habe erst mal kann ich euch auch schon
mal den skin zeigen dass in den ich
derzeit bei meinem neuen account benutze
ist der ihr ich bin luca ich wollte
einfach so ein bisschen meinen alten
stimmt natürlich noch behalten diesen
kontrast das kinn aber ich wollte auch
mal gern ein bisschen nackte haut zeigen
deswegen habe ich jetzt diese hab ich
fucking zuckerrohr deswegen habe ich
mich jetzt für dieses kind hier einfach
entschieden ich habe meine was ein
bisschen modelliert und
hinter der maske es immer noch etwas
verborgen aber das kann man durch grad
nicht sehen muss ein bisschen aufpassen
dass ich nicht über die micro her rede
weil das studium mikrofon ist und das
ist so wenn ich hier rede und das ist
ich finds ich find's super ich versuche
mal kurz auf den gomez server
aufzukommen vielleicht kann ich euch ja
okay ich bin ja noch nicht premium ich
bin jetzt mal einfach auf den heimserver
gegangen mag ich zwar nicht so gern aber
der ist tatsächlich gerade ganz schön
design und das ist ein online server und
jetzt schaut mal kurz in den chat
freunde denn jetzt zeige ich euch meinen
neuen mannschaft nahmen es gebe jetzt
einfach mal einen irgendwie ja das
stimmt und jetzt schaut euch meinen
namen an der ist nämlich ich bin profi
weil ich das bin
das ist jetzt erst mal ein übergangs
account wo ich mir jetzt gesagt hab ja
ich will heute minecraft hochladen und
ich will auch in zukunft noch ein
bisschen minecraft nebenbei zocken wenn
ich irgendwie denn videor ändert oder so
deswegen habe ich mir ein paar namen
überlegt ich wollte mich erst hallo mein
name ist luca nennen das ging aber nicht
wegen den 16 charaktere charakters simon
kjaer 16 buchstaben darf das nur langsam
dann wollte ich mich schon so nennen wer
das liest es doof das war auch so lange
wollte ich mich denn wer das liest
stinkt das paar aber glaube ich schon
vergeben sogar sollte ich machen wer das
liest heckt wer das lief takt wer das
liest fuhr sie waren alle noch frei aber
das ist jetzt nicht so nahmen so ich
möchte ungern bommel sagen du kannst
mich premium machen sie heißen account
ja wer das liest furzt ich bin profi das
ist dann auf jedenfalls ist eigentlich
kein stück besser ja das ist quasi das
einzige was ich jetzt in diesem video
kurz sagen wollte mein neuer minecraft
account heißt ich bin profi das heißt
wenn einer von euch zufällig models oder
jemand der ein mod kennt oder ein hut
mit oder so von ihnen im deutschen
amerikanischen whatever server dann
schickt denen doch bitte dieses video
und zeigt den yukon crafter bitte
erstmal ran wegnehmen und die irgendwie
blocken so dass der nicht zocken kann
der typ der derzeit mein account gehackt
hat und dann einfach jetzt wer ganz nett
wenn dann ich bin profi einfach youtuber
rang bekommt der hat dann zwar keinen
kanal und den namen den gibt es auf
youtube auch glaube ich gar nicht aber
das bin ich
kommt noch eine runde irgendwas da ich
ja so ein pvp profi bin ich bin ja
übrigens seit neuestem sogar profi ich
bin profi habe ich mich für eine runde
survival games hier entschieden
das ist eine ganz ganz alten teppich
beginnen ja gerade immer noch auf ramsey
ich hab auch gerade keinen ob tief ein-
oder irgendwas drin
ich bin nicht auf direkt in die mitte
ich bin profi ich bin profi ich bin
profi ohne sogar absolute mein gott 89
andere spieler haben jetzt vielleicht
schon schwerter oder so ich habe einen
sampling und kann damit die natur
bepflanzen
ich hasse minecraft pvp das ist so
langweilig halo ist hier jemand ja also
können wir auf jeden fall mal gerne in
die kommentare schreiben
ob ihr meinen armen toll findet ob ihr
die mikrofon qualität das würde mich
halt echt interessieren findet ihr das
ok oder sagt ihr nee das ist ja
schlechter als vorher also ich denke
viel schlechter als vorher kann es nicht
wirklich sein ich verlinke euch mal das
letzte video hier da hört man schon hat
scheiße wie die qualität ist wie ich bin
ich kurz davor das video hier jetzt
gerade zu beenden
ich sehe einfach überhaupt gearbeitet
dessen gegner
das war es mit diesem video meine damen
und herren und freunde und freundinnen
wenn es euch gefallen hat würde ich mich
über eine bewertung freuen ich habe
meine minecraft account zwar nicht
zurück da sind wir noch dran mit mojang
am schreiben auch über mein netzwerk
studio 1 70 so ein bisschen so heben
könnte jetzt nicht hinnehmen aber ich
habe jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal neue
county zugelegt damit ich mich etwas
aufnehmen konnte wenn es euch gefallen
hat wie gesagt dann ja